欸，你可能沒想到，有家公司把「回收廢料」這件事做得非常、非常大，甚至還拿到了超過一億歐元的信用額度。
一億歐元？開玩笑吧？回收廢料不是通常賺不了什麼大錢嗎？頂多就是資源回收廠，怎麼會需要這麼多錢？這模式能撐多久？
我一開始也跟你一樣懷疑，但他們這家叫 Metycle 的德國公司，做的不是你想像中那種資源回收。他們鎖定的是工業級別的「二手銅鋁」，而且是把供給量衝到一個非常可靠、大規模的程度。
怎麼說呢？聽起來很玄。一般來說，回收的料就是雜、品質不穩，價格浮動大。哪個工業大廠敢用這種「二手料」當作主要生產材料？
這就是他們厲害的地方。Metycle 的 CEO Rafael Suchan 有句話說得很好，他說：「我們的機會在於讓二手供應的行為更像一種工業原料：有規格、可追溯、可靠交付。」
嗯，這點聽起來就不容易做到。要怎麼讓雜亂的回收品變得有規格、可追溯呢？這成本會不會高到不划算？
他們有三個主要做法。首先是全球貿易營運，他們在全球 15 個國家都有團隊，負責採購、合約和風險管理。再來，他們有 SmartSorting Hubs，也就是智慧分揀中心。
智慧分揀？是像垃圾分類機那樣嗎？
不完全是。他們的 SmartSorting Hubs 用的是 AI 分揀、機械分離，甚至還有雷射誘導擊穿光譜技術，能把混雜的廢料轉換成符合買家規格的原料。第一座 SmartSorting Hub 就在比利時。
哇，用這麼高科技的東西來處理廢料，這確實顛覆了我對回收的想像。那可追溯性呢？怎麼確保來源？
他們還有第三個支柱叫 TrustTrack。這是一個數位層，會把材料來源、品質、加工過程和物流記錄，都連結到每一批次、每一筆交易上。這樣買家就能清楚知道自己買到的二手料是從哪裡來的，品質如何。
這麼一說，的確是把廢料的價值提升了。但就算這些都做到了，要拿到一億多歐元的信用額度，還是很不容易。這中間的轉折是什麼？
其實他們也不是一開始就拿到這麼大筆錢。Metycle 是 2022 年成立的，在 2023 年 12 月才拿到 470 萬歐元的種子輪融資，然後 2025 年 2 月又拿到 1400 萬歐元的 A 輪融資。這次是 Rivonia Road Capital 這家專做資產抵押貸款的私募資本管理公司給的，總額 1.317 億歐元。
資產抵押貸款？所以是他們手上的這些「整理好」的二手金屬原料，變成了一種有價值的資產，才能去借錢，對吧？
對，就是這個邏輯。 Rivonia Road Capital 的合夥人 Daniel Zinn 也提到，他們對 Metycle 的管理團隊印象深刻，認為他們有深厚的產業專業知識，執行力強，而且對擴大規模有清晰的願景。
這樣聽起來就合理多了。他們不是單純賣廢料，而是賣「標準化、可追溯、可靠」的工業原料。這對製造業來說，確實很有吸引力。特別是銅和鋁在電氣化、電網、資料中心這些領域需求很大。
沒錯。 Metycle 也提到，市場對二次金屬的需求不是問題，問題在於「可預測性」。如果能讓二次供應像一次礦料一樣穩定，那就能解決許多產業的材料安全問題。
如果我是製造業主管，我會認真考慮引進這樣的供應鏈。它提供了新的材料來源，同時也符合現在強調的循環經濟趨勢。
是啊。對我們一般上班族來說，這個案例也提醒我們，很多我們習以為常的「廢棄物」或者「沒價值」的東西，其實只要重新定義它的價值，加上創新的流程和金融模式，就能變成完全不同的高價值產品或服務。
嗯，好像也提醒了我們，在自己的工作中，是不是也能找到一些被忽略的「廢料」，透過重新思考、重新加工，創造出新的價值呢？